[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
la comunidad internacional califica de
falsas las elecciones en nicaragua con
las que el presidente daniel ortega
busca legitimar su tercera reelección el
mandatario se encargó de tener el camino
libre para lograrla al arrestar a todos
sus contrincantes y obligarlos a
exiliarse
eric adams fue electo alcalde de la
ciudad más grande de estados unidos es
el segundo afroamericano en lograr el
cargo más importante de nueva york- el
ex policía tiene una visión matizada de
cuestiones polémicas por lo que puede
ser un punto de encuentro entre quienes
piden reformar a las fuerzas de la ley y
quienes las defienden y un campesino
colombiano fue atacado por uno de los
hipopótamos de pablo escobar es el
segundo ataque en el año el
narcotraficante lo sacó ilegalmente de
los lagos de áfrica hasta el país
suramericano por lo que causan estragos
al ecosistema local
primero vamos a revisar la cifra de la
semana 9 37 esa es la cantidad de
cuentas vinculadas con el gobierno de
daniel ortega que fueron eliminadas de
facebook 937 la compañía renombrada
recientemente meta y que aglomera a
facebook instagram y whatsapp informó
que estos perfiles hacían parte de una
granja de trolls que estaba tratando de
manipular la opinión de los
nicaragüenses a favor de ortega de cara
a las presidenciales
recordemos que los contenedores del
presidente fueron arrestados y acusados
por delitos como traición a la patria o
lavado de dinero por lo que la unión
europea y la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos califican de falsos
estos comicios mientras que sus
detractores lo acusan de ir en camino a
convertirse en un dictador como
anastasio somoza al que un día combatió
recordemos su historia en el informe de
jorge hurtado
esto es femenino
una vieja historia con nuevos personajes
el joven ortega abandonó la facultad de
derecho a sus 17 años para unirse a la
guerrilla sandinista el objetivo
derrocar al dictador anastasio somoza en
1967 cayó en prisión donde estuvo siete
años por robar un banco bajo la causa
comunista salió en libertad tras un
intercambio de rehenes y vivió en el
exilio en cuba y costa rica durante los
años setenta americanos cuando el
movimiento armado derrocó a somoza en
julio de 1979 ortega regresó como un
guerrillero laureado aunque no participó
de ningún combate su compañero no
nombraron el rostro visible de la
revolución sandinista por su calmo
temperamento y será el de más bajo
perfil de los guerrilleros e
intelectuales que gobernaban nicaragua
su primer período como presidente entre
1984 y 1990 estuvo marcado por su
política anti americana el bloqueo
económico y la guerra interna tras el
surgimiento de la contra una guerrilla
entrenada por eeuu para derrocarlo
luego de perder las elecciones en 1990
contra violeta chamorro ortega prometió
gobernar desde las sombras continuó como
el único candidato del sandinismo
durante las siguientes tres elecciones
pero las perdió su popularidad no era
suficiente frente al temor de la guerra
o el servicio militar obligatorio tras
16 años en la oposición en 2007 ganó la
elección gracias a una imagen
conciliadora con los empresarios y su
antiguo rival eeuu
[Aplausos]
pero desde esa fecha sus críticos le
acusan de desmantelar el estado de
derecho asfixiar a la prensa y partidos
opositores incluso modificó la
constitución para nombrar a su esposa
como vicepresidente en 2018 rompió
relaciones con la empresa privada y
detonaron masivas protestas en su contra
que saldaron con más de 300 muertos y
miles de restos aislado por la comunidad
internacional ortega encarceló a sus
verdaderos contrincantes liberando el
camino para un nuevo mandato que sus
críticos llaman la consolidación de una
dictadura
[Música]
y es que al menos seis candidatos
presidenciales fueron arrestados en una
ola de detenciones de opositores
iniciada a principios del año y que se
llevaron a cabo bajo la llamada ley de
soberanía que persigue a los que el
gobierno califica de traidores a la
patria revisemos en qué consiste la
legislación
en diciembre de 2020 la asamblea
nacional aprobó la ley 10 55 conocida
como la ley de soberanía una iniciativa
que asegura buscar la defensa de los
derechos del pueblo a la independencia
la soberanía y la autodeterminación para
la paz y tipifica como crimen la
traición a la patria un delito de amplio
espectro la ley dice que es todo aquel
que financió un golpe de estado fomente
actos terroristas o que inciten a la
injerencia extranjera demande o aplauda
la imposición de sanciones contra
nicaragua también incluye a quienes
pidan intervenciones militares y
bloqueos económicos en contra del país
hace parte de un paquete legislativo que
incluye a la ley de regulación de
agentes extranjeros que divide a los
ciudadanos entre en verdaderos
nicaragüenses y agentes extranjeros a la
ley de ciberdelitos conocida como la ley
mordaza por limitar el contenido en
internet y criminalizar el ejercicio
periodístico el objetivo es limpiar la
cancha y presentarse finalmente a unas
elecciones presidenciales el 7 de
noviembre sin que exista un competidor
sea capaz de derrotar a ortega el
paquete legislativo también incluye una
reforma que amplía de 48 horas a 90 días
el tiempo de detención durante la
investigación los hasta ahora detenidos
son acusados de delitos supuestamente
cometidos antes de la promulgación de la
ley lo que según decenas de abogados es
además inconstitucional pues las leyes
no son retroactivas por lo que
presentaron varios recursos de apelación
ante la corte suprema de justicia que ya
anteriormente ha demostrado estar a
favor de ortega como en 2009 cuando
admitió el recurso del presidente a
aspirar a la reelección de 2011
y la corte penal internacional inicia
una investigación formal contra el
estado venezolano por crímenes de lesa
humanidad las pesquisas se centrarán en
esclarecer las denuncias de tortura y
ejecuciones extrajudiciales
presuntamente cometidas por las fuerzas
de seguridad venezolanas durante las
protestas antigubernamentales de 2018 el
anuncio llegó después de una visita a
caracas del fiscal de la cpi karim khan
invitado por el propio nicolás maduro
quien respondió que respeta pero no
comparte la decisión
y como es tradición el primer martes de
cada noviembre hay elecciones en eeuu
esta vez los comicios fueron vistos como
un termómetro de la gestión de joe biden
tras casi un año de su elección el
partido demócrata al que pertenece el
mandatario sufrió un revés al perder la
gobernación de virginia por primera vez
en más de una década el estado voto
republicano en nueva jersey el demócrata
phil marfil logró reelegirse como
gobernador pero no fue nada fácil pues
sólo obtuvo un 1% más de votos
y además en la jornada electoral
mineápolis rechazó la reforma a la
policía y en nueva york' dirigió un
nuevo alcalde que gobernará a partir de
enero es el demócrata eric adams luís
muñoz nos cuenta más sobre este policía
retirado afroamericano el segundo en
llegar a la alcaldía de la gran manzana
[Aplausos]
[Música]
es eric adams el nuevo alcalde demócrata
de nueva york será el segundo
afroamericano en gobernar la ciudad en
su discurso de celebración reafirmó la
personalidad mostrada en campaña
hermanos y hermanas y toda la gente de
nuestra ciudad ya hablaron y esta noche
nueva yor escogió a uno de ustedes
yo soy ustedes yo soy que ustedes
después de años de rezar y desear y
luchar entramos al alcalde quién wajed
sucedió
en la jornada de votación del martes
eric adams acudió a votar con un retrato
de su madre fallecida el pasado año ha
sido uno de los ganchos de campaña para
llegar al ciudadano de a pie
adam suele hablar de su infancia pobre
se define obrero es vegano y considera
haber sido traicionado por las
instituciones cuando su madre no podía
comprar comida o cuando siendo
adolescente era golpeado por policías
precisamente adams fue ex capitán de
policía y hasta su lanzamiento de la
carrera de alcalde presidente del
distrito de brooklyn
así se expresaba en 2020 sobre el que ha
sido otro de los grandes pilares de su
campaña la seguridad
nos acostumbramos a creer que la
violencia es normal en nuestra comunidad
pero no lo es
estas madres perdieron a sus niños no
son solo fotos
adams destaca por haber sabido llegar a
los distintos grupos sociales de la
ciudad consiguiendo 9 millones de
dólares de recaudación de campaña lo
cual le costó el cuestionamiento por
parte del ala más a la izquierda del
partido demócrata su periodo de gobierno
comenzará en enero cuando sustituirá al
actual alcalde bill de blasio
con este signo version south y vamos a
colombia que está teniendo dificultades
para lidiar con otro de los indeseables
legados de pablo escobar los hipopótamos
que el narcotraficante llevó al país
ilegalmente y que se reprodujeron
descontroladamente debido a que el
ecosistema del país cafetero es mucho
más amable que su hábitat original en
áfrica los hipopótamos se adueñan de
cada vez más territorio y han terminado
agrediendo a los campesinos mientras
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos de los animales se quedan
cortas en propuestas sobre cómo proceder
la hacienda nápoles la tierra de los
sueños del más famoso narcotraficante de
colombia 2000 hectáreas de pasto de
bosques y de lagos artificiales un
pequeño paraíso para estos hipopótamos
creado por pablo escobar la mayor manada
salvaje fuera de áfrica de donde son
originarios los hipopótamos de escobar
son la estrella del parque temático
construido en la finca incautada por el
estado tras la muerte del capo
hipopótamo
son descendientes de los cuatro
especímenes extraídos en los 80 al zoo
privado de escobar se reprodujeron y
ahora son más de 100
no están bajo condiciones de tres no
tienen depredadores
el clima de colombia les favorece
muchísimo entonces
perfecto quiere realizar en la población
3 de ellos viven en el parque los otros
viven en libertad a la par que se
multiplican forman nuevos grupos que
colonizan el territorio se pueden
encontrar incluso a más de 150
kilómetros de la hacienda nápoles los
hipopótamos atraen a los turistas como
estos estadounidenses pero provocan un
serio impacto en el ecosistema y la vida
local es un arma de doble filo para
nosotros los operadores del turismo de
naturaleza queremos mostrarlos pero nos
preocupa muchísimo su presencia a menudo
invisibles estos gigantes son un peligro
para los habitantes de la región no muy
lejos del tour que realiza camilo el
guía un campesino fue atacado y herido
de gravedad se estaba comunicando con un
compañero mío que con un compadre
cuando el animal me atacó lo único que
sentí yo cuando lo guardo atrás ya no
fue el único que yo sentí no me he
perdido
y la pierna y la espalda desde entonces
quedó incapacitado y sin dinero un grave
accidente pero no el único según algunas
estimaciones para 2050 los hipopótamos
podrían contarse por miles de vez en
cuando ya se les puede ver incluso en
las calles de algunos pueblos el futuro
de los hipopótamos de escobar es un
rompecabezas para los científicos no hay
una solución definitiva por el riesgo
por decir que lo vamos a matar todos eso
no es posible decir que lo vamos a
capturar todos tampoco casi 30 años
después de su muerte el legado de pablo
escobar sigue pesando sobre colombia
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo rodrigo sedano sigan
con más en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]